business people in an 8th grade
classroom coaching the kids the idea
seems strange at first but the kids are
enthralled by what the coaches have to
tell them about how to manage and make
money once they leave school about
whether to stay at home or move out and
about making intelligent choices in life
another engrossing topic where does
their pocket money actually come from
and once they turn 18 will their parents
pay for a snazzy new smartphone or will
these kids be on their own can you
finance a heady lifestyle by taking out
alone and what's the difference between
gross and net the questions are endless
yes songul it's good to learn about this
stuff at school it helps prepare us for
life flighted well as I shouldn't some
dis think it's hard to think about the
future every once in a while anyway
about what I want to do with my life how
to handle money sensibly some visu you
should always keep that in the back of
your mind asia-pacific northern swamp
does it I want to get good grades so I
can go to university and earn enough to
buy a house and a car the input by
real-life business people is welcomed by
their teacher pietra carbon she says
kids listen closely when Outsiders tell
them about the real world and what they
do out there it's Finn tired shoulder
Sawyer schools nowadays are supposed to
do a variety of things help kids grow up
teach them specific subjects prepared
them for life for employers but how at
some point your studies are over so why
not enlist the help of experts it's been
I'm present the whole time I can react
if something goes on that I don't like
on the children definitely profit from
it the kids also like the exotic
interlopers from the working world says
Bettina vendor
normally she's an insurance sales woman
but she's volunteered to teach kids
economics for four years she enjoys
passing on the knowledge she got from
her job dr. wolf embark to see so many
young people get themselves into debt
before they even reach the proper age
for such a thing officially by hanging
by signing mobile phone contracts and
things like that we try to prevent that
and teach them what real life is like to
live mas one potential objection to the
project is that the financial coaches
could try to manipulate the kids by
giving them biased information bettina
vendor for instance works for the aliens
insurance company but her students are
never told that the coach with sapna
coaches pledged not to overwhelm the
students with one-sided messages and
start controversial discussions product
promotion is explicitly not allowed no
one's allowed to name individual
products that's a fundamental principle
and the students are to be treated with
respect back behind o fish in the end
the kids get a certificate they now know
that it will cost at least 1,000 euros a
month to run a household that was
shocking news but they also learned ways
of coping the school principal is
pleased regal music we're always hearing
from businesses that there aren't enough
trainees and people with specialized
skills Doumit lovallo businesses and
schools have begun cooperating um not
traditional for a long time there have
been internships where school kids go
out into businesses not only is that
legitimate it should be encouraged
sundin hacer pardalis verdict our
children being turned into conformist
consumers as some critics fear
ultimately that depends on what else
they learn from schools and their
parents